if you are looking for a weekend getaway
the casablanca resort who is sponsoring
this next segment has it all and if
you're looking for weekday action they
have that too here to tell us about the
annual mesquite amateur is christian
anderson with the casablanca resort
welcome thanks for having me again
always great to see you always the
captain of fun you always bring
entertaining stuff tell me more about
this golf tournament that's taking place
next week absolutely once again the casa
blanca is the home of the great special
events in mesquite so this one's no
different the mosquitoes are second
largest amateur event in the nation uh
so golfers come from all over the
country to come play it's uh any golf
handicap age you play with people of
likeability and golf and like age you
can come and participate in a first
class tournament how many participants
you can have next week we're excited we
have 660 players this year oh that's a
lot absolutely and they're coming from
41 different states in the country and
our player that's coming the furthest
coming from england this year to come
participate so we're real excited to
welcome everyone back that excites me
before we we came on the air you're
telling me about the is the bruce king
scholarship would you mind sharing that
with everybody absolutely this is our
ninth year doing the bruce king memorial
scholarship and and bruce was one of our
inaugural players he played the first 10
years of our tournament unfortunately
passed away to cancer in 2012
but the players that he met there the
community of mesquite met so much to him
players came together developed this
great scholarship so money's raised
during the tournament at silent auctions
we have some great pre-tournament
activities to raise money for this and
this year we gave a 6 000 scholarship to
a senior at virgin valley high school
it's a great thing how many golf courses
are up there
so that we actually use six in the
mesquite amateur itself
and you play some of the best courses in
mesquite and i think one of the great
things that makes mesquite such a great
golf destination is when you stay at the
casablanca resort you had six courses in
six minutes of your hotel wow so you
have to go play the great great golf
that mosquitoes offer but the best part
about that you get to enjoy the
casablanca resort when your round's over
and we have plenty to do in that resort
now next week is the big golf tournament
this sounds like a blast the weather
should be great it's a great time of
year this weekend memorial day weekend
someone wants to get out of town it's a
short drive up there there's still rooms
there's so good stuff going on this
weekend absolutely grab them fast
because we have a lot of folks already
coming in but we love to have anyone
come up for this week and enjoy the casa
blanca and our sister property the
virgin river hotel as well and then i'll
go back to next week's event that's a
family-friendly event anybody can attend
and come watch the tournament yeah so
it's open to the public free to come
watch we we have players like i said
coming from all over the country to come
do it so people are coming out they can
definitely come and watch the great golf
that's out there
but i think for the people that are
coming they're real excited to see their
friends that they maybe only see one
time a year at the mesquite amateur golf
tournament if someone's watching they
kind of want to do like a group outing
maybe take the office bachelor
bachelorette party do you guys do group
outings when it comes to golfing
absolutely we we have a great group of
uh i call them golf concierge and they
take care of everything for those groups
coming out your tee times your hotel
rooms if you have any special activities
you want to have on the golf course
longest drive close to the pen they'll
make sure that's coordinated with the
golf courses cold beers i think we
handle that as well i love it and so we
they really take care of the event from
soup nuts all the way to the end and
make sure you and your group have a
great time away at the cosplay awesome
thank you so much christian we
appreciate it the 19th annual mesquite
amateur starts may 30th for more
information call
1-877-getaway or just visit casablanca
resort.com